[Music]
[Music]
you can be a mail fairy no no no no I
mean nature mine is actually good Oh
should be you'll be fine yeah that's
cameras if anything it's the opposite
you're weightless turn it left putting
me in our harness left left it could be
interesting wrong way wrong way totally
why are you listening to me that's good
his camera looks a little cold to my
heart hey gerald
I don't know if I want to hear this
gerald do you do I can only take so much
did you know Stephen today paid you a
big compliment where's this hanger this
sounds like a lie I asked him where we
should do really does sound like a lie a
live show and he said notre-dame you
should I did what a long time ago at st.
Mary's but except the day we want to do
your Spring Break so [ __ ] you why oh
they do yeah next year they do it on st.
Patrick's Day Spring Break no but st.
Patrick's Day is on a Tuesday so he did
the Thursday before it's spring break
for them really
so we'll go somewhere else that seems
odd somewhere less educated plus Rudy
didn't deserve to be on that line yes he
did no I didn't yes
he didn't he did it's a family he did he
didn't look this was my department of
action he did he did because he mopped
floors because he really wanted to know
so everyone else worked their entire
life to get good at football he decided
later in the game that he wanted to be
on a on a football team and a division
one football team now he had no business
being there he wasn't good enough no he
made the practice squad okay he put in
his time they played an inferior
opponent they were beating the hell out
of he got to dress for one game he
earned it that's what they do for us no
I didn't know the rule was that every
person on the practice squad gets to
play they don't oh I didn't prove you
just don't dig about sports like
football know something educate me so
everyone a practice squad gets to play
why does no I don't accept your bonfire
to know about football yeah we'll see
the best on a practice squad no don't
accept that premise either you act like
those things are the things that matter
what are the things I
the entire stealing and Sandow should
play maybe athletically capable to play
on one of the finest didn't compliment
finest athletic did he do that for two
years
no oh he didn't go out to practice every
single day they practice I got to
practice
nope not everybody made the practice
squad because people trying to practice
didn't get the player better than him
they weren't better than obviously so he
was the best in practice quite maybe we
don't know he was the best on the
practice squad at that position
hey guys watch out later he's a jerk but
yeah really really yeah but he's not
wrong and being able to play like it's
okay yes
all right the real issues okay it's so
inspirational McKee was gifted a spot
that he didn't deserve well you don't
you don't count the work that he did
during the the time during practice to
say that he would potentially cross the
threshold of all of earning it I do
count the work I do count the work just
like everyone else in the practice squad
I'm saying he wasn't good enough the
reason he was put on there was because
of sympathy not because of ability
that's true
it was sympathy not ability I don't have
to say it if I don't agree with you I
think he earned the opportunity and the
coaches decided look this guy is paid
his duties never gotten on the field
you're not gonna go down in history as
playing for the team if you don't so hey
we'll put him out there against the
nature of the beauty of this there
doesn't need to be an I feel or I think
the numbers would substantiate it if he
would if he was the best in the practice
squad was he no no it's not that is that
fully only practice go ahead and say all
right who's the best you guys get to
suit up in a game that doesn't matter
that's not our word yes how strings and
sports work no that's not had that first
word here goes and then the second tier
and it's a guy right we didn't put in
will back that one in
yeah well put that get to choose they do
get to choose so they chose hey I'm
choosing to put a very chosen inferior
he didn't get a sack either he didn't
know that was Holly I cannot believe
my eye socket Zach didn't even sadi that
just proves my point even more he was on
the practice squad none of those things
are true practice what is undeserving
they put him on the field and after all
this he did nothing I think he jumped on
top of the player while they were
getting tackled but did been doing that
the whole time
he didn't even sack anyone top of the
guy who was doing the sack boy not quite
but just like he jumped over the top of
the person who deserved that spot in the
first place it's people who are more
deserving than ham not true not true if
you enjoyed this video you can subscribe
or hit the notification bell and one of
these buttons or watch another video but
you know this this thing is you don't um
I mean you don't you don't have to I'm a
dive I'd like it if you did you know a
lot of effort and do it hmm whatever you
want